Scaffolding is a way of creating
a starting point structure for
your project based on a couple
of assumptions that you control.
If say, all you do is create single page
movie promotions during your work hours,
your gulp file might look
very similar every time.
In that case, writing it from scratch
over and over is inefficient.
And it's very likely that you've already
done the most basic form of scaffolding
plenty of times, copy and paste.
To be fair, that's a perfectly
valid way of doing things.
But it's not the most elegant
in the world of web development.
Let's take a look at some
premade scaffolding tools.
You'll find links to all three
in the instructor notes.
If you're just starting out,
the HTML5 Boilerplate is a nice
scaffolding starting point.
All it does is give you a decent basis
for your CSS, HTML and JavaScript.
It makes sure your HTML is well formed,
that fall backs are provided and
that your CSS is normalized.
On top,
it ships convenient stuff like JQuery.
It has a simple build script to
combine and minify files, but
doesn't come with Gulp or
any other advanced build tool.
You already passed that stage.
For an intermediate solution,
check out the Web Starter Kit.
It's an opinionated starting
point that we've built at Google
that already includes a built
configuration with live editing and so
on, but
it won't fit every project out there.
And finally, Yeoman for the advanced
users, to which I'm counting you now
that you've reached almost
the end of our course.
Yeoman is the most flexible
solution of the bunch.
Use it together with so
called generators that fit the job.
After calling Yeoman with the generator,
in this case the web app one,
Yeoman asks you a few
questions about what you need,
then creates an empty project
template based on your preferences.
It's basically a much fancier
version of copy and paste.
Okay, why talk about this now,
at the end of the course?
There's no point in letting a
scaffolding tool generate a project and
build template that you have
no idea how to use and modify.
Now that you know all the basics,
you'll be much more confident
trying out various Yeoman tasks.